British and U.S intelligence say Iranian
troops are on the ground in Crimea
supporting Russian drone attacks on
Ukraine it comes as the Ukrainian
military continues a counter-offensive
in the Strategic hersan region an area
that was annexed and put under martial
law by Russian President Vladimir Putin
let's have a look uh in a bit more
detail in the situation on the ground
we're joined Now by retired Air Vice
Marshal Sean bellshawn good to see you
again well so a big picture sort of
breakdown for us first of all on the on
the situation on the ground yeah
mentioned that house and start off there
and the ukrainians are tightening the
news around the tens of thousands of
Russian troops that are held up in there
Russian officials have been told to
leave by the Kremlin and there's also
reports of some of the Russian soldiers
um running around in civilian attire
almost certainly is that so they can get
off our away from house and without
attracting the attention of the media
um General sarovicin who's the most
senior Russian general looking after all
the Russian forces in Ukraine has hinted
that the situation is not going well in
Harrison which is unheard of that they
would emit such weakness but it seems to
be set in the conditions for a Russian
withdrawal from uh from from the city
we'll have to wait and see interestingly
president zielinski has also accused
Russia of mining the kakov hydroelectric
part plant Dam this Dam right up in in
the top here provides one of the very
few Crossing points for the Juniper
River for the Russians because obviously
all the bridges have been blown uh
elsewhere now if they if the Russians
were to blow that down which they've
actually occupied for uh since the start
of the war that will cause massive
flooding down the deeper River but also
all the way around Harrison what looks
most likely is if the Russians are
planning to withdraw if they were to
blow that Dam they would flood that
River flood person and therefore cover
their Retreat the challenge would be it
also devastate Water Supplies to the
south of Ukraine and also that's where
the cooling water for the reactors at
zapparicha comes from let's touch as
well Sean on that issue of reports that
there are Iranian troops in Crimea
helping the Russian operate drones I
mean how significant is that yeah the
last 10 days the Russians have been
focusing on targeting Ukrainian energy
infrastructure all across the country
let's be fair these are not military
targets it's much more about terrorizing
the military population the civilian
population they've been using these
Iranian drones these Shahid 136 we've
covered them in in some detail on
previous days you tend to think of
drones as being slow with very little
limited endurance these drones they're
generally launched out of Crimea but
their range is well over a thousand
miles and that takes them anywhere in
the country of Ukraine might take quite
a long time to get there but they
certainly got the range for that Iran
has deployed some extra people military
expertise to support the operation of
the Russians of operating these drones
out of uh Crimea and as a result of that
technical support and the arrival of
these drones both the UK and the US have
imposed additional sanctions on Iran and
then children just talk us through the
significance of that story that Ben
Wallace the defense secretary told us
about yesterday from from a few weeks
ago where a British aircraft what nearly
got shot down by Russian aircraft or is
that a that's the wrong thing well it's
an amazing story this because the event
happened on the 29th of September over
three weeks ago but it was only
announced by Ben Wallace yesterday
um that su-27 flanker we've got a
picture of one here Russian fighter
aircraft uh released the missile very
close to a royal Air Force airplane that
was operating just over the Black Sea
the target was a royal Air Force RC 135
and rivet joint airplane we've got a
picture of one here these are these
provide the eyes and the ears over the
battlefield they routinely fly over the
the Black Sea a crew of about 30 on
board the Russians claim that this was a
result of a technical malfunction
whereas you know I'm a former fighter
product myself and I can tell you that
technical malfunctions do not lead to
the firing of missiles that that is a
completely implausible what's much more
likely is the Russians are very
frustrated at the West's use of air and
space power to support Ukraine and as a
result they've almost certainly been
trying to try their luck the flights of
the rc-135 have resumed again but now
they have typhoon aircraft providing
armed escort
but if this Destroyer turned out
differently if the Russians had been
successful if the missile had hit this
target it would have massively escalated
the whole situation and we'll be
covering a very different story
certainly were Sean thanks so much as
always